magnus his rook was under fire so he
just steps it back
one square he actually gave up the pride
and joy of his position he gave up that
pawn but
now black's pieces are tied up and
magnus magnus is the one shaking his
head now
magnus has just had to move his rook
wow okay maybe magnus has missed this
one he's had to give back a rook for a
night
black's knight was threatening the white
queen threatening some pawns
suddenly uh ivanka all better off
anything could happen in this game
magnus he's completely lost his material
advantage
black is the one who's a pawn up now
okay magnus calmly just advancing the
white king
i think magnus over the last few moves
he's completely panicked
he saw the clock situation and well he
couldn't handle hikaru's dynamism he
couldn't handle the energy and that was
something that
hikaru is so good at you know you've
really
got to be a little bit more practical i
mean i actually lost the game completely
one game against hikaru
because i didn't respect that talent too
much and
now i'm looking at the position and i'm
thinking
hikaru has great chances to hold the
position at least i mean blacks are pawn
up right
black's got her very far advanced
passport yeah but still
just hold it yeah and you just defend it
with your rook
yeah probably but it still looks a bit
scary for uh
hikaru right now and will he adjust to
this big
change because he was totally lost and
was in hustling mode
and i was expecting him to resign
earlier right i thought he was dead lost
uh but okay he does now attack the white
queen the white queen will have to
find a safe square i mean magnus if he
doesn't win this one
he's had winning positions against
napolita he had a winning position
against giri earlier in the tournament
he failed to finish those guys off
wow they just agree a draw there's still
so much life in the position
hikaru offered to draw magnus accepted
magnus he blew that one miraculous save
by nakamura and look at magnus's face he
knows that was another missed
opportunity in this tournament
he looked like he was so close to a very
important win in the first game here
and he misses it he doesn't fight on
what's happening